from a
technical perspective john you've looked
at
mixed martial arts fighting in general
and grappling what's the difference
between fighting and grappling
that's something i'd love to
ask all of you maybe john you can start
like um well uh
when you talk about fighting you mean
unrestricted
uh mma tough time fighting yeah this is
fine you said unrestricted mma tough
mma type fighting so there's there's
there's stream fighting yep there's mma
fighting and then there's grappling
that's really the sport of grab you're
saying okay what's the difference
between mma and grappling yes okay um
see that would have been a much better
question yes um well the uh
the single when you talk about grappling
you're talking about jujitsu rules or
yeah i mean you could maybe also mention
different rule sets that somehow
fundamentally challenge that change in
the sport you know
um in the sport of mixed martial arts
you've got two
ways to inflict damage on the human body
you've got kinetic energy which is done
through striking
kicking knees elbows fists
and you've got uh isometric tension used
along the lines of
lever and fulcrum
which can be used for strangulation and
joint braking
um
in grappling you lose one of those
you're no longer allowed to hurt your
opponent with kinetic energy you can do
it accidentally through a throw but
you're not allowed to just
you know knock someone out with a throw
in most grappling spots it can happen
but it's relatively rare and it's it's
not encouraged by the rule set
so um cyborg with uh
yeah he got close
so
there's a sense in which in mixed
martial arts you got twice as many
problems to deal with
and
and they occur
in
a much shorter time frame the single
biggest difference between grappling
technique as a weapon
in human combat versus striking
technique is time
grappling technique takes a huge amount
of time to apply okay
the great advantage of grappling
technique is certainty of outcome once
you get there
it takes a huge amount of time to set up
a takedown
physically take them down
work their way
work your way towards a dominant
position culminating in your opponent's
back and then apply a stranglehold
that's a long chain of events
as opposed to
a strong punch or kick which can take a
quarter of a second an application from
start to finish and the match is over
um
and so
there's a sense in which
uh grappling is is it's
it's fighting for the patient and the
calculating
whereas striking
is much more for
in this short time frame where
everything gets done and
in the blink of an eye there's a sense
also in which grappling is a much more
forgiving sport you can make a terrible
mistake
end up in a terrible position and still
fight your way out and win
in mixed martial arts it's
much much less forgiving
if you get hit and stunned your chances
of recovery are minimal you're going to
get swarmed on and unless it's right at
the end of the round you it's very very
hard to recover from getting hit and
swarmed on
um
so there's a sense in which
the biggest difference between them is
time for application of technique uh in
mixed martial arts it's incredibly
unforgiving in terms of time even the
smallest error can have the deepest
consequences
in grappling you can make massive errors
and still come back and win
grappling will typically be won
in a much higher percentage case by the
more skilled and conditioned grappler
whereas there is
much more of what they call a punches
chance
in mixed martial arts where
there's a much higher likelihood of a
lesser athlete defeating a greater
athlete in mma than there is in
grappling simply because of time of
application of the techniques even the
smallest period of inattention in mma in
the match is over gordon ryan could fall
asleep for 30 seconds
have his opponent mounted on and wake up
and finish him five minutes later it's
not gonna happen in mma
okay so the the stakes are much higher
you can do a lot of damage in a very
small amount of time and just the
dynamic the temporal dynamics of how
things happen is very different
everything you'll see will be a
reflection of that then you go further
into things like rule sets
in the sport of grappling if gordon ryan
comes out and sits down in the middle of
the mat his opponent must follow him to
the ground and engage
in mixed martial arts
if you come to the center of the cage
and sit down
the other guy can just walk away from
you they're completely
oriented in different directions
grappling is ground-centered mma is
typically standing centered at the
beginning of every round you have to
start standing again if i disengage from
a ground grappling situation stand up
and walk away from my opponent my
opponent must follow me up to the feet
in grappling it's the exact opposite if
i sit to the ground my opponent must
follow me to the ground it's written
into the rule set and so one is
inherently ground or oriented and one is
inherently standing oriented so it's
more it's more difficult to dictate
where the fight happens in mixed martial
arts yes you have to be able to impose
where the fight is whereas in grappling
you can simply choose it
so
george
what is uh your sense of the the
difference in terms of how you
approached it
between the two sports so you also are a
student of wrestling and grappling
so in preparing for fights
what parts of grappling
purely the sport that you have to leave
behind
well i i uh
i'm very lucky i had the opportunity i
train with i consider the best
mentor trainer i ever ever had
and i have
some of the best grapplers that i can
train with they were they were there to
help me through my career
so
for my training is
of course because i do not dedicate as
much time in one specific area it's hard
to be
you know a world-class athlete and that
in in only one particular area always
for me
like the idea to be more well-rounded to
be very competent in every of those
areas striking grappling and
takedowns and and all those areas than
being just
very good at one
and
not as good at as as others you know
because i like the idea that
it gives me more option when i fight
someone
i can
mold myself to become the perfect
nemesis to
that person better if i'm more
well-rounded
if i do not have those well-rounded
skill
i don't have that option you know
you have less tools to work with less
technology
what about you gordon what um
you know what do you think is very
distinct about grappling in the way you
approach it versus fighting i think most
of it was covered but i think that
though the one one of the big things is
the fact that when you're looking at mma
you have a pretty general agreed-upon
and unified rule set where
if you look at ufc versus bellator there
they have slight differences in the
rules maybe um but it's pretty much the
same thing whereas in grappling you have
ebi rules and you have adcc rules you
have ib gf rules you have no time limit
rules
and
each rule set will play to the skills of
different athletes
if you have if you do adcc rules
it generally is slightly biased towards
wrestlers or if they can stall to the
overtime
and then hit a takedown in the overtime
and not really do any jujitsu but they
score a takedown they're going to win
whereas if you have like an ebi for
example you have to finish the guy in
regulation or you start in a jujitsu
position with your back taken or
in an arm bar
so i think that
you have
certain rule sets that play in the favor
of certain athletes
and
certain athletes can win in one rule set
but then they just have no chance of
winning in the other like when i fought
yuri the first time in ebi i beat him in
ebi the chances of me beating him on
that night under an adcc rule set were
probably pretty low
when i fought leandra lowe under an adcc
rule set he beat me that day but the
chances of him beating me in the same
day in an ebi rules that were like next
to zero
so i think it's interesting that
in in mma you have one unified rule set
which has small differences but they're
all generally the same and in jiu jitsu
you have a wide variety of different
rule sets that
have
biases towards
certain athlete skill sets